This lecture is about how to use
generative probabilistic models for
text categorization.
There are in general are two kinds of
approaches to text categorization by
using machine learning.
One is generative probabilistic models,
the other is discriminative approaches.
In this lecture, we're going to talk
about the generative models.
In the next lecture, we're going to
talk about discriminative approaches.
So the problem of text categorization
is actually very similar to document
clustering in that we assume that each
document belongs to one category or one
cluster.
Main difference is that in clustering
we don't really know what are the
predefined categories or what are the
clusters.
In fact, that's the goal of text
clustering.
We want to find such clusters in the
data.
But in the case of categorization, we are
given the categories.
So we kind of have predefined
categories and.
then based on these categories and
training data, we would like to
allocate a document to one of these
categories, or sometimes multiple
categories.
But because of the similarity of the
two problems, we can actually adapt
document clustering models for text
categorization.
Or we can understand how we can use
generative models to do text
categorization from the perspective of
clustering.
And so this is a slide that we've
talked about before about text
clustering, where we assume there are
multiple topics represented by word
distributions.
Each topic is 1 cluster.
So once we estimate such model, we
faced the problem of deciding which
cluster document d should belong to and
this question boils down to decide
which theta i has been used to generate
D.
Suppose D has L words represent
represent as Xi here.
Now, how can you compute the
probability that particular topic word
distributions theta i has been used to
generate this document?
In general, we use bayes rule to make
this inference.
And you can see this
Prior information here.
That we need to consider if a topic or
cluster has a higher prior then it's
more likely that the document has been
from this cluster, so we should favor
such a cluster.
The other is a likelihood part, that is this
part.
And this has to do with whether the
topic word distribution can explain
the content of this document well.
And we want to pick a topic that's high
by both values.
So more specifically, we just multiply
them together and then choose which
topic has the highest product.
So more rigorously, this is what we
would be doing, so we're going to
choose the topic that will
maximize this posterior probability of
the topic given the document.
Get posterior becausw this one P of
Theta i is the prior, that's our belief
about which topic is more likely.
Before we observe any document.
But this conditional probability here
Is the posterior probability of the
topic after we have observed the
document d.
And Bayes rule allows us to update this
probability based on the prior and
I shown the details.
Below here you can see how the prior
here is related to the posterior on the
left hand side.
And this is related to how well this
word distribution explains the
document here, and the two are related
in this way.
So to find the topic that has the
highest posterior probability here,
it's equivalent to maximize this
product as we have seen also multiple
times
in this course.
An we can then change the probability
of document in your product of the
probability of each word and that's
just because we've made the assumption
about the independence in generating each word
OK.
So this is just something that you have
seen in document clustering.
An we now can see clearly how we can
assign a documentary to a category based on
the
information about word distributions
for these categories and the prior on
these categories.
So this idea can be directly adapted to do
categorization and
This is precisely what Naive Bayes
classifier is doing, so here it's
mostly the same information, except
that we're looking at the
categorization problem now, so we
assume that if
Theta i represents category I
accurately that means the word
distribution characterizes the content
of documents in category i accurately.
Then what we can do is precisely
like what we did for text clustering.
Namely, we are going to assign document D
to the category that has the highest
probability of generating this
document.
In other words, we're going to maximize
this posterior probability as well.
And this is related to the prior and
the likelihood an as you have seen on
the previous slide.
And so naturally, we can then decompose
this likelihood into a product.
As you see here now here I changed the
notation so that we will write down the
product as product over all the words
in the vocabulary and even if even
though the document doesn't contain all
the words and the product is there
accurately representing the product of
all the words in the document.
because of this count here.
when a word doesn't occur in the
document.
The count would be 0, so this count
would just disappear.
So effectively we're just have the
product over all the words in the
document.
So basically with naive Bayes
classifier, we're going to score each
category for a document by this
function.
Now you may notice that here
It involves the product of a lot of
small probabilities and this can cause
underflow problem.
So one way to solve the problem is to
take logarithm of this function, which
doesn't change the order of these
categories, but would help us preserve
precision and so this is often the.
This is often the function that we
actually use to score each category,
and then we're going to choose the
category that has the highest
score by this function.
So this is called a Naiyes Bayes
classifier.
Now the keyword Bayes is understandable
because we are applying a Bayes rule
here.
When we go from the posterior
probability of the topic to a product
of the likelihood and the prior.
Now it's also called a Naive because
We've made an assumption that every
word in the document is generated
independently, and this is indeed a naive
assumption, because in reality they are
not generated independently.
Once you see some word and other words
will more likely occur.
For example, if you have seen a word like a
text, and then it makes categorization or
clustering more likely to appear
And if you have not seen text.
But this assumption allows us to
simplify the problem, and it's actually
quite effective for many text
categorization tasks.
But you should know that this kind of
model doesn't have to make this
assumption.
We could, for example, assume the words
may be dependent on each other, so that
would make it a bigram language model
or trigram language model.
And of course you can even use a
mixture model to model what the
document looks like in each category.
So in nature they will be all using
Bayes rule to do classification, but
the actual generative model for
documents in each category.
Can vary, and here we just talk about a
very simple case.
Perhaps the simplest case.
So now the question is, how can we make
sure each theta i actually represents
category i accurate?
Now, in clustering we learned this
category i or the word distributions
for category i from the data.
But in our case what can we do to make
sure this theta i represents indeed
category i?
If you think about the question and
you're likely to come up with the idea of
using the training data right.
Indeed, in text categorization, we
typically assume that there are
training data available and those are
the documents that are known to have
been generated from which category.
In other words, these are the documents
with known categories assigned, and of
course human experts must do that.
And here you see that T1 represents the
set of documents that are known to have
been generated from category one, and
T2 represents the documents that are
known to have been generated from
category two, etc.
Now if you look at this picture, you
see that the model here is really a
simplified unigram language model.
It is no longer mixture model.
Why?
Because already know which distribution has
been used to generate which documents.
There's no uncertainty here.
There's no mixing of different
categories here.
So the estimation problem of course
would be simplified, but in general you
can imagine what we want to do is to
estimate these probabilities that I
marked here and what are the
probabilities that we have to estimate
in order to do categorization where
there are two kinds.
So one is the prior.
The probability of theta i and this
indicates how popular each category is
or how likely we would have observed the
document in that category.
The other kind is word
distributions and we want to know what
words have high probabilities for each
category.
So the idea then is to just use the
observed training data to estimate
these two probabilities.
And in general we can do this
separately for different categories.
That's just because
these documents are known to be
generated from a specific category, so
once we know that it's in some sense
irrelevant what other categories we
are also dealing with.
So now this is statistical estimation
problem.
We have observed some data from some
model and we want to guess the
parameters of this model.
We want to take our best guess of the
parameters.
And this is the problem that you have
seen.
Also several times in this course.
Now, if you haven't thought about that
this problem, haven't seen  naive
Bayes classifier, it would be very
useful for you to pause the video for a
moment and to think about how to solve
this problem.
So let me state the problem again, so
let's just think about category One.
We know there is one word distribution
that has been used to generate
documents.
And we generated each word in the
document independently and we know that
we have observed the set of N sub one
documents in the set of T1.
These documents have been all generated
from category one, namely have been all
generated using this same word
distribution.
Now the question is what will be your
guess or estimate of the probability of
each word in this distribution and what
will be your guess of the prior
probability of this category?
Of course, this second probability
depends on how likely that you will see
documents in other categories.
Right, so think for a moment that how
do you use all these training data,
including all these documents that are
known to be in these K categories.
To estimate all these parameters.
Now if you spend some time to think
about this and it would help you
understand the following few slides.
So do spend some time to make sure that
you can try to solve this problem or do
your best to solve the problem
yourself.
Now, if you have thought about it and then
you will realize the following intuition.
First, what's the basis for estimating
the prior or the probability of each
category?
Well, this has to do with whether you
have observed a lot of documents from
that category.
Intuitively, if you have seen a lot of
documents in sports and very few in
medical science, then your guess is
that the probability of sports category
is larger or your prior on
the category would be larger.
And what about the basis for estimating
the probability of word in each
category?
Well, the same and you'll be just
assuming that words that are observed
frequently in the documents that are
known to be generated from a category.
will likely have higher probability, and
that's just the maximum likelihood estimator
indeed, and that's what we could do.
So to estimate the probability of each
category.
And to answer the question which
category is most popular, then we can
simply normalize the count of documents
in each category.
So here you see n sub I denotes the
number of documents in each category.
And we simply just normalize this count
to make this a probability.
In other words, we make this
probability proportional to the size of
training dataset in each category.
That's the size of the set T sub i.
Now, what about the word distribution?
Well, we do the same again.
This time we can do this for each
category.
So let's say we are considering category I or
Theta
I.
So which word has higher probability?
Well, we simply count the word
occurrences in the documents that are
known to be generated from theta i.
And then we put together all the
all the counts of the same word in this set.
And then we just normalize these counts
to make this distribution of all the
words make all the probabilities of all
these words sum to one.
So in this case you can see this is a
proportional to the count of the word
in the collection of training
documents.
T sub I and that's denoted by C of w and T
sub I.
Now you may notice that we often write
down
a probability estimate in the form of
being proportional to certain number,
and this is often sufficient.
Becausw we have some constraints on
these distributions and so the
normalizer is dictated by the
constraint.
So in this case it will be useful for
you to think about what are the
constraints on these two kinds of
probabilities.
So once you figure out the answer to
this question and you will know how to
normalize, this counts and so this is a
good exercise to
work on it if it's not obvious to you.
There is another issue in Naive Bayes
which is a smoothing.
In fact the smoothing is a general
problem in all the estimate of language
models and this has to do with what
would happen if you have observed a
small amount of data.
So smoothing is the important technique to
address data sparseness.
In our case the training data set can
be small and one data set is small.
When we use maximum likelihood
estimator we often face the problem of
zero probability.
That means if the event is not
observed.
Then the estimated probability would be
0 in this case if we have not seen a
word in the training documents for,
let's say, category I, then our
estimate would be 0 for the
probability of this word in this
category.
And this is generally not accurate.
So we have to do smoothing to make sure
it's not zero probability.
The other reason for smoothing is that
this is a way to bring prior knowledge,
and this is also generally true for a
lot of situations of smoothing.
When the data set is small, we tend to
rely on some prior knowledge to
to solve the problem.
So in this case our prior knowledge
says that no words should have
zero probability, so smoothing allows
us to inject this prior to make sure
that no word has a zero probability.
There is also a third reason, which is
sometimes not very obvious, but we'll
explain that in a moment and that is to
help achieve discriminative weighting of
terms.
And this is also called IDF weighting
inverse document frequency weighting
that you have seen in mining
word relations.
So how do we do smoothing?
Well in general we added pseudo counts
to these events.
We'll make sure that no event has zero
count.
So one possible way of smoothing the
probability of category is to simply
add small nonnegative constant Delta to
the count.
We pretend that every category has
actually some extra number of documents
represented by Delta.
And in the denominator
we also add K multiplied by Delta
because we want the probability to sum
to one.
So in total we've added Delta K Times
because we have K categories.
Therefore in the sum we have to also
add K multiplied by Delta as a total
pseudo counts that we add to the
estimate.
Now it's interesting to think about the
influence of delta.
Obvious Delta is a smoothing parameter
here, meaning that the larger delta is
and the more we will do smoothing and
that means we'll more rely on pseudo
counts and we might indeed ignore the
actual counts if delta is set to
Infinity.
Imagine what would happen if delta
approaches positive Infinity?
Well, we're going to say every word has
infinity amount of sorry, not every
word every category has.
infinity amount of documents, and
then there's no distinction between
them, so it becomes just a uniform.
What if Delta is zero?
Well we just go back to the original
estimate based on the observed training
data to estimate the probability of
each category.
Now we can do the same for the word
distribution, but in this case we
sometimes we find it useful to use a
non-uniform pseudo counts for the
words.
So here you see we'll add pseudocounts to
each word and that's mu multiplied by
the probability of the world given by a
background language model.
Theta sub b
Now that background model in general
can be estimated by using a large
collection of text, or in this case we
can use the whole set of all the
training data to estimate this
background language model.
But if we don't have to use this one,
we can use larger text data that are
available from somewhere else.
Now if we use such a background
language model to add pseudocounts, we
find that some words will receive more
pseudocounts.
So what are those words? Well those are
the common words.
Because they get higher probability by
the background language model so
the pseudocounts added for such words
would be higher, rare words on the other
hand will have smaller pseudocounts.
Now, this addition of background model
would cause nonuniform smoothing of
this word
distributions we are going to bring the
probability of those common words, or
to a higher level because of the
background model.
Now this helps make the difference
of the probability of such words
smaller across categories.
Because every category has some help
from their background for words, like the, a
which have high probabilities.
Therefore it's no longer so important
that each category has documents that
contain such a lot of occurrences of
such word, or the estimate is more
influenced by the background model and
the consequences that when we do
categorization, such words tend not to
influence the decision that much as
words that have small probabilities.
From the background language model,
those words don't get some help from
the background language model, so the
difference would be primarily because
of the differences of the occurrences
in the training documents in different
categories.
You also see another smoothing
parameter mu here, which controls the
amount of smoothing, just like delta
does for the other probability.
And you can easily understand why we
add mu to the denominator because that
represents the sum of all the pseudo
counts that we add for all the words.
So mu is also non-negative constant and it's
empirically set to control smoothing.
There are some interesting special
cases to think about as well.
First, let's think about when mu
approaches Infinity.
What would happen?
Or in this case, the estimate will
approach to the background language
model will tend to the background
language model, so we would bring every
word distribution to the same
background language model.
And that essentially removes the
difference between these categories.
Obviously we don't want to do that.
The other special cases we think about
the background model an suppose we
actually set the two uniform
distribution and let's say one over the
size of the vocabulary.
So each word has the same probability.
Then this smoothing formula is going to
be very similar to the one on the top.
When we add Delta because we're going
to add a constant pseudo count to
every word.
So in general, in naiyes bayes
categorization we have to do such
smoothing and
once we have these probabilities, then
we can compute the score for each
category for a document and then choose
the category with the highest score
as we discussed earlier.
Now it's useful to further understand
whether the naive Bayes scoring
function actually makes sense, so to
understand that.
And also to understand why adding a
background language model will actually achieve
the effect of idea of IDF weighting and to
penalize common words.
Right, so it's suppose we have just two
categories and we're going to score
based on their
Ratio of probability, so this is
Ann
let's say this is our scoring function
for two categories.
So this is a score of a document for
these two categories.
And we're going to score based on this
probability ratio.
So if the ratio is larger
then it means it's more
likely to be in category one, so the
larger the score is, the more likely
the document is in category One.
So by using bayes rule we
can write down this ratio as follows and
you have seen this before.
Now, we generally take logarithm of
this ratio and to avoid small
probabilities, and this would then give
us this formula in the second line.
And here we see something really
interesting, because this is our
scoring function for deciding between
the two categories.
And if you look at this function, we'll
see it has several parts.
The first part here is actually log of
prior probability ratio and so this is
the category bias.
So it doesn't really depend on the
document, it just says which category
is more likely and then would.
We would then favor this category
slightly.
So the second part has a sum of all the
words.
Right, so these are the words that are
observed in the document, but in
general we can consider all the words
in the vocabulary.
So here we're going to collect
evidence about which category is more
likely.
So inside the sum you can see there is
product of two things.
The first is count of the word.
And this count of the word serves as a
feature and to represent the document.
And this is what we can collect from
document.
The second part is the weight of this
feature.
Here it's the weight on each word and
this weight.
Tells us.
To what extent observing this word
helps
contributing to our decision to put this
document in Category One.
I remember the higher the scoring
function is more likely it's in
category one.
Now if you look at this ratio basically
or sorry this weight
It's basically based on the ratio of
the probability of the word from of
the two distributions.
Essentially we are comparing the
probability of the word from the two
distributions and if it's higher
according to theta one, then according
to theta 2 then this weight would be
positive and therefore it means when we
observe such a word.
We'll say that it's more likely to be
from category One, and the more we
observe such a word, the more likely
the document will be classified as theta
one.
If, on the other hand, the probability
of the word from theta one is
smaller than the probability of the
word from theta 2, then you can see
this weight is negative.
Therefore this is the negative
evidence for supporting category one.
That means the more we observe such a
word, the more likely the document is
actually from theta 2.
So this formula now makes a lot of
sense, so we're going to aggregate all
the evidence from the document.
We take a sum over all the words we can
call this the features.
That we collect from the document that
would help us make the decision and
that each feature has a weight that
tells us how
does this feature support category
one or support that support the
category two, and this is estimated as
the log of probability ratio.
Here in naive Bayes.
And then finally we have this constant
of bias here, so that formula actually
is a formula that can be generalized to
accommodate more features.
And that's why I've introduced some
other symbols here.
So introduce the beta zero to denote
the bias and Fi to denote each feature,
and then beta sub i, to denote
the weight on which feature.
Now if we do this generalization, what
we see is that in general we can
represent the document by feature
vector F, FI here.
Of course in this case FI is the count
of a word, but in general we can put
any features that we think are relevant
for categorization.
For example document length or the font size
or counts of other patterns in the
document.
And then our scoring function can be
defined as a sum of constant beta zero
and sum of the feature weights over
all the features.
So if HF sub I is a feature value then
we multiply value by the
corresponding weight beta sub i and we
just take sum and this is to
aggregate.
All evidence that we can collect from
all these features. And of course there are parameters here. So what are the parameters? Well
These betas are the weights, and with appropriate settings of
weights then we can expect the such a
scoring function to work well to
classify documents.
Just like in the case of Naive Bayes
we can clearly see naive Bayes
classifier is a special case of this
general classifier.
Actually, this general form is very
close to a classifier called logistical
regression, and this is actually one of
those conditional approaches or
discriminative approaches to
classification.
And we are going to talk
more about such approaches later, but
here I want you to know that there's a
strong connection close connection
between the two kinds of approaches,
and this slide shows how naive Bayes
classifier can be connected to a
logistic regression.
And you can also see that in
discriminative classifiers that tend to
use a more general form on the bottom,
we can accommodate more features
to solve the problem.